Perfect.
We are live.
Goal number one is to figure out the
whole environment mess.
What's up with our vectorzation?
Goal number two is to refactor. I forgot
to grab one thing and we will get
started with
Right. So, if I recall what was
happening last time, we had this really
weird performance disparity.
Okay. So,
here's the OM performance with
uh with breakout and then we had there's
a different test
Right. So, this was the disparity. Um,
cuz this is pretty much the same code,
right?
Ah, it does.
It does. Okay.
Interesting.
So, it's a very, very minor little
difference, it turns out.
with just the way actions are being
computed.
Right. So, and now it goes back up in
perf. Okay. So, that's all it was. It
was just like this very, very minor
little quirk. Cool. Uh, we should be
able to go from here.
Yeah, let's just go with no action being
added.
And actually, do I want to try to fill?
I think that it's fine. We'll use this
as a test.
Yeah. And we'll leave this like this.
So,
uh, the next thing we need to do now do
is go revisit
some of the tests.
right? because it was with
multi-threaded is the uh the test from
before and this is quite fine
performance.
We do
direct
8192 m and 8. And the goal is to get
this to map
Well, we have this thing passing
anyways, right?
Uh, okay. It's opening some weird DLL.
Let's figure out why it's doing that.
Yeah, I like went through this way too
quick yesterday.
Hello. Good morning.
What are we working on today? So, we're
going to fix up the M speed test, I
think, and then we're going to um
uh we're going to work on cleaning up
puffer for pre-alpha.
Okay, so this direct test here gets a 71
mil,
which is pretty close.
80 mil from the native file.
Take a quick look.
Can you tell me what we're working on?
So, two things today.
The first one is fixing up and having a
good understanding of the performance of
our vectorzation.
And the second one is a large general
cleanup of puffer so that we can get
this thing uh well so we can get you all
playing with it essentially so it's
clean enough to play around with it for
pre-alpha.
Uh well, okay. So, this is just calling
random crap,
But we now know the target's actually
like 80
80 mil.
And yeah, that's nowhere close.
So presumably I've just made a mess of
this and I have no idea what's even
getting cold anymore.
Let me see if I remember what mess
because I'll just have it undo it.
Or is it just I let it make a mess.
Stupid.
We need this flag.
Other than that,
other than that, I think this might be a
referable. We might have to just um
stash and reset.
Okay, so this is still reasonable here,
right?
CPU.
Do you have any Oh, hang on. Do you have
any idea where I can start an RL? I'm a
B Tech student. Yeah, I got you. Hang
on. I have a guide.
Let me put this chat where I can see it
more easily.
If you're new to RL, the place to start
is right here.
Engagement CS researcher app on some
project which will help others.
Uh it depends if you want like how deep
you want to get into research.
This also this guide will give you
starting points for both of those
though.
It's like um I spent quite a while on
this. This is going to give you a much
better answer than I can give you just
off the cuff here. This is pretty much
like a step by step on how to get into
RL and how to start thinking about
research.
Okay. So, this is 54 mil.
Yo, good luck. Thank you.
Right. So the one flag I did remember
helping
or was this flag I think it was like no
semantic something or other a sub.
Good thing I mean this is all open
source work as well. I run probably the
largest, no I think definitely now the
largest uh RLD dev community open
source. Uh we also write the highest
performance software in the field. So if
you're interested in learning, I mean we
have a ton of people around that came in
with no RL experience, no AI experience
even, and are now doing some pretty
awesome stuff. So it can be done. It
does take some work. But the one thing I
can promising you I can promise you is
that the way we do stuff around here
uh you will learn a lot more directly
from the stuff you do. There's a lot
less bullshitting around than there is
in most coursework or more traditional
stuff.
I mean I have that too if you want it
but
mostly this
Okay, so I think there's a combination
of two different things going on here. I
think what happened uh first of all I
screwed up the test because I didn't
realize that there was a huge difference
if you set the actions or not in the M
speed
and then the second thing is compiler
shenanigans
no. Okay. Yeah, I was testing if there's
like some caching break point, but no.
Did we get any perf out of this? Oh, we
did get a maybe we got a little bit.
It's hard to say.
Also, we don't have this on the ocean
one anyways, do we?
Uh, but this is for DLS. Okay,
so let's now do what is it? The minimal
test.
Test barrier standalone.
No, this is not the one.
Speed static. Yeah, this one.
Breakout minimal.
This is what we want. So we want
something that just loads the thing and
runs the test and then we see what we
get from that
I can't type today. I don't know what's
wrong.
We should see if it's compiler crap. Um,
here. Now I can actually get it to do
this from here most likely.
cool good morning?
I want to create a large 10,000 plus
agent environment in 2D with continuous
coordinates and continuous movement
actions. Do you have any pointers? Yeah,
I got you here. Easy. 10K is a lot
though, man. Um, I would do 8192.
That's going to saturate batch size. If
you really want to do it, you can do I'd
do two copies, like two environments
with 8192 each, two instances. That's
going to be more hardware efficient. You
can do one environment in 16K if you
really want. I don't recommend it
though. So, this is like one of the a
the environments we have with a ton of
agents.
This is the convert environment. It's
very simple. It's only a few hundred
lines of code if you want to look at it.
Um it's just a bunch of agents that are
observing like the near like the nearest
targets and a couple other things and
then they school in this really cool
pattern. And this trains in a few
seconds. It's really fast.
The only reason I actually I train it
with more agents than this as well. I'm
limiting the number of agents that
you're seeing here because it's deployed
on web with a really inefficient CPU
neural net.
Like I literally I wrote the neural net
for this for the browser. It's really
slow
but you can scale this to thousands very
easily.
The one thing that the pointer for you
is you want to avoid anything quadratic
with that many agents.
Easiest way to do that is to just put
agents into chunks.
Oh yeah, multi-agent interactions will
work. The big thing is you're going to
need to do chunks or something though
because you can't have um you cannot
have quadratic checks over 16k agents.
You can get away being lazy with
quadratic up to a few hundred agents
and still have it be fast because C is
fast.
After that, at the very minimum, you
partition the map into chunks and then
you make sure that your game is not or
your environment is not such that all
the agents bunch up in one spot.
That way you only have to check um you
know agents in the same chunk or agents
in adjacent chunks at the most.
Much faster.
Oh, this is dumb.
Yeah. Yeah, this is super super dumb.
Okay, we'll leave alone dumb claw. We'll
do our own stuff now.
give it a try. Oh yeah. You make
anything cool and it's not private,
consider pring.
So many cool projects out there to be
done and a lot of them end up being
useful for research.
I think the easiest way that we test
this, right, is we just do um
we do like one buffer.
Yeah, let's just not be stupid lazy
here.
So instead of having this barrier crap
and all this
like what is this man?
It's kind of funny. I created the
perfect example of why not to overuse
Claude in the process of literally doing
throwaway crap.
I actually think that it is going to
just be better to do this.
cuz now I don't have to deal with all of
its crap. And we mostly have the stuff
we need from it anyways.
There. Now I'm back to dealing with my
own stuff.
The one thing I did want though was the
cuz I think I wrote that test, right?
Damn it.
Great.
Great example of not what of what
exactly not to do.
Dummy. Why I do that?
Why did I do that?
there.
That's all we wanted, right?
So now we can just do profile. Was it
profile? Um
min
MS speed total agents number one num
thread zero
horizon Doesn't matter. Use GPS is
false. No. Yeah, it's good. Okay.
then. This is the correct warm-up. Very
nice.
collapsed.
I'm just I'm trying to like I'm flexing
with a bunch of crap here.
It'll all get clearer in a second.
Uh, I'm fussing with like a whole bunch
of crap here though essentially because
I made a mess by overusing Claude trying
to like just figure out I was trying to
root cause something and I left the code
in a weird state. So basically I need to
remove all the stuff that Claude did.
Anyways, um but I there's one last test
I need before I can do that.
So, if it was not clear, yes, these
models are incredibly stupid.
Working on RL. Yep, that's all I stream.
We build the highest performance
reinforcement learning tools out there.
Pretty much everything except LLMs.
We're also not big into um super high
dim continuous control,
but that's mostly uh
What did I do? I just like mistyped
everything. Did it right?
OM minimal vex step. So yeah, this is
the profile version.
Yes, this one's not even needed.
Good. Causal interferencing.
Uh, that's broad. What exactly?
16-year-old and 11th learning about CS
and AI like ML. Any suggestions how to
advance learning Python with it? Yes, I
actually I have
I have all of my best advice in one
place for you here.
I wrote this article like this is pretty
much all my best advice and if I'd
actually listened to this when I started
it would have saved me thousands of
hours.
It's not like a step by step on how to
learn programming in general. Um but it
has all my best advice. This one is a
step-by-step guide, but it's for RL
specifically.
But hey, RL is cool because you can
actually, at least now with Puffer, you
can do it at home.
You can train models at millions of
steps per second on a decent laptop.
Double machine learning difference.
No.
Is this like second order optim stuff?
What? I'm not sure what this is.
No. Yeah. And this is outside of my
area, ma'am.
I've not seen this stuff.
It's more than I can just like read up
on in 30 seconds.
Okay. Break out. P
minimal
vibe coding. Do not do that, dude. You
will not learn.
It'll feel really cool because you'll be
able to build stuff fast, but you will
not learn stuff.
You can use the models. It's very
tempting to overrely on. In fact, what
I'm dealing with right here is because I
overrely on a model even for like
throwaway tests and I let it screw some
stuff up just trying to diagnose a
problem. Uh, and that's somebody with
like 15 years of experience who should
really know better and who actually like
I actually know what I'm doing
independent of these models. Um,
I'm not going to say don't use them at
all, but my advice around that is in
that article. you really really want to
learn stuff at a very low level. Not
like the go take a course. Those are
very that's not actually a lot of the
information you need, but you do need to
be able to build stuff end to end and
know exactly what's going on. And models
take you away from that most of the
time.
given treatment variable
affects the outcome
of research. I'm just going to solve it.
No,
it's pretty far off. The stuff I work on
uh Zanch is I do ultra high performance
simulation like sims that run at
millions of steps per second and then I
make models on the scale of a few
hundred like a 100 thousand to a few
million parameters
uh train at millions of steps per second
and with RL and enough data that's
actually enough to solve very hard
problems and uh it's completely
unoptimized
uh the algorithms
behind it are very brittle uh because
mostly the code is very slow. So it's
like a very heavy engineering heavy area
at the moment where there's a huge
opportunity for progress just simply
because uh it's an area where stuff was
running literally a thousand times
slower than it should have
or more 10,000 in some places.
So I build really high performance tools
for RL. I do algorithmic research around
them. It's all open source. That's uh
and I stream all of it.
Coding later, math first. Uh I actually
think there's pretty minimal math that
you need for ML. Like the stuff you're
doing is probably different, but you
really you just need to have uh you need
to know multivaried derivatives. Pretty
much just the chain rule because that's
the core of all of Autograd.
My own stats background sucks. I think
the ma vast majority of ML can be
understood through either stats or
through linear algebra. Linear algebra
has always been easier for me. And for
the most part, it's not even like the
math department's version of linear
algebra. It's just a a bunch of tensor
operations.
Can you increase the volume of the mic a
tiny bit? Yeah.
Try that. Let me move it a little
closer. It gets stuck behind um
behind my monitor.
there. We'll try that. See if that's a
little better.
Oh, okay. This is weird.
So, this is this being slow is very bad.
So, this essentially tells us there's a
compilation issue, right?
RTX 5080
space
5080 is plenty for RL.
You can train millions of steps per
second on that.
that's the other fun thing is we do not
need Blackwell chips for RL because we
don't need the memory. Our models are
tiny.
Very powerful though. Like it's not just
a toy.
It's one of the few areas you can do
like really meaningful research without
needing to scale models a ton. You do
scale data. We train on more data than
all of OpenAI. Uh and we can do it on
one GPU.
Hello. What are you doing? This is my
daily or at least most of the time most
days stream. uh I develop high
performance RL live.
We are currently what I'm doing right at
the moment is I am diagnosing
an issue in which we have our
multipprocessing implementation for
different environments. It's working
well on the standalone test, but then
when I compile it as part of the whole
build, it's not as fast as it should be.
In layman terms, I'm not much of a
coder.
Uh, the really layman's version of this
is
I make AI that trains on games really,
really fast, like millions of times
faster than normal. And the algorithms
are really general, and a lot of
problems look like games. So the stuff I
do ends up working on control problems
and robotics. It ends up working on
markets. Uh it ends up working on a wide
range of applications.
And I am a researcher. I've been working
on this stuff for a decade. And I stream
all of my dev live.
Just a quick version for sleepy uh
Thursday morning.
any of Josh Garman's? No.
You probably already Yeah, I don't
really go through much ML content like
that anymore, man. Um,
you know, I kind of have my own stuff at
this point.
And also I do produce a little bit of
educational content but it's kind of as
a byproduct
like just the way that I build stuff. I
focus a lot on simplicity, speed and
simplicity. So it just ends up being the
case that a lot of what I do is very
accessible to people. Uh and people like
to learn off of it. But that wasn't even
the objective when I started this. It
was more of just like a watch know watch
cutting edge research being done live
and chat about it kind of a thing.
cool idea to streaming work. Yeah. And I
don't actually lose any productivity
because any time that I lose uh talking
to chat on stream is time that I would
just normally lose spacing out if I were
not streaming. So I actually find it's a
nice way to focus my thoughts and um I
enjoy work more doing it.
You work for any corporate? I have my
own company. So Puffer is a fully open
source, but it's also a private lab and
we build high performance simulators for
other companies for clients on request
and we integrate our RL tools with those
in order to train agents.
Are there free modules to use on puffer?
Everything is free in puffer. Literally
everything is puffer and puffer is free.
Orange data mining.
I don't Orange data mining.
Fine. Hire me. We do hire um it's all
contracting based at the moment. We do
pick people for contracts though out of
the uh the contributors. There is quite
a high bar, but we do people we do pull
people from uh for from the contributors
for contracting work.
That's what I like about open source.
It's just pure meritocracy.
just bored with Amazon. Uh yeah, I did
an internship there. It was uh
very boring.
Yeah.
I don't know. With the type of stuff I'm
doing at the moment, it's just it's very
difficult for me to make full-time stuff
reasonable because as soon as I hire
people full-time, I have to guarantee a
steady stream of work, right? So, I have
to pay people less in order to offset
the uh the times in which there will not
be as many contracts. Whereas, when I do
everything via contracting, I just get
to split stuff 50/50 with people. And
nobody's ever mad about a 50/50 split.
It's very fair.
Free coding for beginners.
I'm not an I'm not an educator like that
though. And I especially I have some
advice for beginners. Um, but most of my
stuff is directed towards people who
have been coding for a bit and like, you
know, maybe have not gotten the best
advice and are looking for they know a
bunch of things, but they don't really
know the correct way to be doing things
and tend to make a mess of stuff. That's
where my advice is best.
And the article that I wrote has most of
it. Like it literally if you just read
that article and like really understand
what it says and just try to do that for
a few projects, you'll get much much
better if you're in that sort of a
place.
It's the type of thing where like I
probably couldn't have taken my own
advice back at the time, but if I could
have, it would have made a huge
difference.
Okay, so this is the correct test.
So it's pure compile diff, right?
Oh, wait. Am I dumb? Break out. No.
What did I do here?
Yeah. 78 mil.
I don't mind working with newer people
as long as they have the right mindset
for it.
I mean, the thing that usually happens
is there are a lot of people that have
done some programming maybe even for
like many years and just have not had
good advice. Programming is terribly
terribly taught. Like the vast majority
of uh of programming instruction even at
the best universities in the world
teaches you to be a terrible programmer.
Programming really is not complicated.
It's very simple, but it's not easy.
Simple does not mean easy. And the vast
majority of programming instruction
vastly over complicates it.
In fact, I was guilty of this, right? I
wrote Python for 10 years. I wrote a
bunch of crappy code. But the thing is,
I spent so much time trying to
understand all the different ways of
doing stuff and like really caring about
writing better things that when I
eventually sort of stumbled onto the
right path, within a month I was set.
It was like a very very quick change in
the way that I approached stuff uh based
on my previous experience and a lot of
people can do the same thing like I've
seen it happen with several of our
contributors.
I mean this is why I like C so much.
If you just
try to write things in C in
the simplest way possible
there, it just doesn't give you the
tools to screw stuff up. It's a very
simple language.
Old school. No, see actually old school
C is the simple thing. Like if you just
don't use double pointers almost ever.
I mean your main tools are conditionals
and loops and that's it.
We have like 50,000 lines of C and
Puffer.
That's not like just bloated, right?
It's for 30 different environments. Uh,
our individual chunks of CC code are the
same length or sometimes shorter than
the equivalent Python and a thousandx
faster and more readable.
Hard disagree. You haven't seen our CC
code here. Let me link you this
here. Let me link you like this is just
a simple demo environment, but you can
look at some of our other ones.
Obviously, there are contributors of
different skill levels, but here look at
this. This is one of the first things I
added to Puffer. And you'll see that
this is super easy.
You don't need any of that, dude. Check
this.
This is This is a multi-million step per
second RL environment for Snake and S.
It's 300 lines of code.
Yeah, sure. If you like you can do that
type of stuff, but the default in C if
you just like write the code top to
bottom in the simplest way possible
like you see how simple this is, right?
I can show this to any first year
undergrad. one course in systems
programming and they will understand
this.
You sort of need those when the systems
get large. Look at this.
So, here's the miniature MMO in C.
So, a few thousand lines, 2,800 lines.
Okay, this is a mo this is over a
million steps per second on one CPU
core. Uh, it compiles to web, it
compiles locally. We can train agents on
it. It's the hardest available
environment in reinforcement learning
that is also fast.
A good 1500 or,500 lines of that are
graphics.
It has a market. You can buy and sell
stuff on an exchange. Has an equipment
system. Couple different leveling
systems.
I can show that code to any first year
undergrad. They can read it top to
bottom.
And I wrote that when I was actually
relatively new to C as well who did the
graphics. So uh I did the like the
programming for the graphics. The assets
are from mana seed.
You can just buy a license on a one
project license on itch.
You don't have to be an exceptional
coder. Well, first of all, data science
isn't really a job, okay? Like,
nobody really describes themselves as a
data scientist at the high end.
Um,
to be good in AI, you don't have to be a
good programmer. There are people that
are very effective in math. I'd say that
there are way more people though that
are ineffective because they are bad
programmers than ineffective because
they are bad at math.
There were a lot of people who were
really good at math at MIT that just
made a mess because they were bad
programmers.
Pretty small. We have dynamic entities
in a pool.
Uh, I mean, depending how big the pool
is and how often it gets refreshed, you
just literally loop and look for empty
slots.
I mean, really basic stuff gets you
very, very far,
Yeah. I mean, when you get to large
projects, right, sure, when you get to
really large projects, stuff is always
going to be complicated. But one of the
things that I've always been very good
at is I take projects that are medium
complexity that you could easily have a
company with a couple dozen people on.
And I have seen companies of a couple
dozen people on similar problems and
then I take them down to a level where
it's like very very simple, few thousand
lines of code, individual can read all
of it, very simple architecture, still
super fast.
And that's kind of the that's kind of
the zone that you want to be in because
that's already enough to build like
groundbreaking new stuff out of
That's weird.
Let's do that.
engineering
but I am a researcher man.
So my background is I'm an MIT PhD.
I produce the fastest tools in
reinforcement learning. I have some
blogs on X that you can read. In
addition, I have published papers for my
PhD. Now I mostly just do my research in
blogs because it's a much faster cycle.
uh we have very effective new methods
right that we discovered because our
program like our code is so fast we can
just search uh we can exhaustively
search over the space of methods so much
more effectively
you know there's some new algorithmic
stuff as well we have a brand new
architecture in the next version of
puffer so I do both
but like in my mind science is a set of
methods it's a tool right it's a set of
approaches so is engineering the goal is
to advance
different problems in the field are
going to require different approaches
and for the stuff I do it's like 80%
engineering maybe 10 15% science
good system design solves a lot of
problems changing the language
complexity yeah
I don't mind I will say um I don't mind
uh I don't mind Zigg it looks fine I
just don't really need what it provides
for what I do like if I want an arena uh
was Is it area or arena? I either way
you can just implement one and 10 lines
if you want. Right.
There are a couple nice things that Zigg
does, but I really don't need them.
multiream doesn't pass questions from X.
Uh, I really need to switch this to
Streamlabs or something. Reream is just
bad.
General rule of thumb is if I don't
reply and you don't see it above my head
here, I don't see your message.
QL straightness. Yeah.
And that's kind of what I figured. Like
the things that bother me with C,
they're just a very small number of
things where it's like why doesn't this
this code should totally compile? Uh
this code shouldn't compile, right?
You can fix most of them with a standard
set of compile flags as well. uh most of
the problems that I have, you know, like
some casts that give warnings, some
casts that don't give warnings. It's
like a very small set of stuff though.
And mostly the other programming
languages, they have a they have a much
broader idea of things that are wrong
when in fact there are very few things
that I think just are not good.
I mean this is closer to 5975.
Is this consistent?
Probably it was using all 16 threads
before. 55
only dependencies are text handling
stuff. Graphics API. So graphics Ray Lib
is awesome like awesome awesome. Um text
I will say that text processing in C is
a total pain in the ass. That one I will
admit.
I mean, this is probably like all the
exports or some garbage, right?
Dash share or the DL Simmon direction.
Okay, we can try that. And then after
that, I'm going to just try to minify
the vec file so that it just doesn't
export so much stuff because it's just
super bloated, I think, at this point.
What's this?
Okay, this is a fine standalone test.
It's a fine stand. I'm just letting it
write some throwaway tests. It's
literally just a compile diff, I think.
Yeah, this is fine. It's just a compile
diff. This possibly lets us isolate what
it is. And if not, then I think I just
have to minify it myself.
Can you run the Muan test? It doesn't
pass for me. Uh, which one?
to LLM do too much and be like [ __ ]
Yeah, absolutely. I do not think these
LLMs are smart. I think that they're
like they're the design is very
antihuman.
like it's very much the UI and the way
that it's set up is very much designed
to like make you hand off too much
control to it. It's very bad. Um I I
will admit absolutely in this case I
overused it. My defense is that I'm
tracking down some awful compiler pork
at the moment and I was just trying to
have it write a bunch of throwaway tests
that like I don't keep but I made the
mistake of letting it touch one of the
files that I shouldn't have. Um, I kind
of didn't notice. I think I actually fat
fingered the like auto accept button at
one point.
So, absolutely, I'm with you. Don't
overuse these things. They're really
dumb and they make you not think.
Good to know on my end. Could be torch
version. Could also be I don't have
stuff committed. Man, I wouldn't worry
too much. Um,
were wait, were you the one who
submitted that patch?
I think it was that you wanted
there was some difference where you want
nestrov EMA, not nestro momentum, I
believe, for muon. Um because you don't
want to match the torch muon. The torch
torches version of muon is wrong. They
use the wrong momentum
might be disturbing you. What are you
doing here? I'm new and I'm interested.
So I do high performance reinforcement
learning dev. I stream all of my
research and we also do a bunch of
engineering to make everything very
fast. At the moment, I'm working on a
multipprocessing back end for running a
lot of simulations in parallel, and we
have it running really fast in the test.
And for whatever reason, when I put it
in the main build, it's not fast or
there's a performance gap at least. So,
I'm trying to figure out why.
I don't doesn't pass on default. It's
probably some library version.
Okay, that's good to know.
Here,
are you in the container?
I've got torch 291 here.
I think this is a CUDA 128 belt.
No, it shouldn't be doing this.
even got a test on Puffer Tank. Fair
enough. I mean, puffer tank like I'm
going to have to add a bunch of packages
and stuff for um 40, I'm sure. My goal
for today is to figure out our NVC stuff
cuz that's driving me nuts and then to
really start cleaning some things up
and then we'll see if Jonah comes back
later with uh BF-16 or if it takes him
another few days.
We've had two awesome awesome new
contributors that have both just like
rocked some low-level optimization on
the uh the latest code.
Got us from 9.6 I believe up to um or
9.8 up to 11.8. So I think about a
million steps per second each off of
them.
Pre-extracted locals to eliminate
pointer chasing in hot loop.
There's no way it's that.
We're putting more high quality C. Well,
this is not high quality C. This is a
god awful mess. I will clean this up.
Oh, actually, since you're an
experienced Cub, um I actually can I run
this design by you real quick? Um
cuz I'm having this is like nightmarish
hell of shared library stuff at the
moment. So we've got like 20 different
environments. Um we've got like 20 plus
different environments, right? They're
different simulators. They all have the
same API. They need to be
multi-threaded. Uh every experiment is
only ever going to use one environment.
So the design at the moment that we have
is I have this binding file that has the
multi-threaded code and it just like has
a couple name macros to define the API
for different ends. You compile that
entire thing. So the vec plus the env uh
as a single shared library and then the
training code uh just dynamically loads
that. So you just load the DL for that
or whatever the shared object for that
and um then you can train. And then the
point of doing this is that you can very
quickly recompile and build any of your
environments without having to have them
all included. So if you have bugs or
compiler quirks with one end, it doesn't
stop you. Also, the torch build is super
slow and uh this build is instant. So it
lets you recompile your end code really
quick. Uh the annoyance with this is
that I end up with some weirdness with
shared libraries at the moment where
it's really difficult to find where some
small performance drops are coming from.
Is that like a completely stupid way to
be doing it with shared libraries?
Because I can't think of anything else
that would let you like have a fast
compile path and not have weird
namespace collisions, etc., etc.
Other constraints torch like that.
It's mostly like torch is this big
absolutely terribly designed C++ library
right and our environments are really
simple clean C and then the
multipprocessing code that we have or
multi-threading code it's like you know
maybe a couple hundred lines worth of
stuff it's not that complicated uh it is
very fiddly though and it needs to be
applied the same to all the ends
Well, there are no docs because this is
all in development, right? Like this was
not the uh this was not how we had it
done before. Uh the way that I had it
done before uh the environments were
bound to Python. So everything was just
like a standalone that was loaded to
Python with the Python C API. But now
since we're not going through Python
like that, uh it needs to be accessible
from C++.
So that was the best way I could find to
have like um the C included with C++
without having the super expensive torch
recompilation every time.
Let me get rid of this bot.
I mean the the nice thing about this
look extensions if I look like this,
this is the type of binding file that
you write. So you write something that
looks like this, right? You can see that
I have the end macro defined. I've got a
couple size macros defined. I've got a
couple standard functions here. And then
this uh is used to hook into the
environment
and um as a result you can run
multipprocessing or multi- threading on
all the environments like this.
But you need to do shared lives. And I
don't know if there's any good way to do
it without shared libraries.
Oh, okay. So,
you take this massive massive hit.
I wonder how it scales. Hang on. We
might be like looking for nothing here.
Yeah, we might just be looking at
nothing.
Test multi
really interested in learning I'm still
beginner I learn fast you guide me on
what I should learn if you're new to RL
you start here if you're new to if
you're relatively new to programming in
ML You start here. These two guides,
they're on my ex, which is Juarez,
all free content.
Let's see. This is 6 mil.
So,
times it 48 gets to 30 mil.
It's not terrible scaling.
So I guess the thing that I'm concerned
about then is
let me see what happens. So wait, if I
go from 32 to 65,
I want to get to the point where I'm no
longer
and basically everything is always not
cash
and we don't get slow down from more m
anymore.
basically where we get no cashing
benefit. Okay, so we're here, right?
There's no cashing benefit almost
20.
But then for some reason when you
multi-thread it,
it still goes down, right?
I think what we do is we go clean up. We
export as little as possible.
We track performance.
We keep monitoring this gap, but like
this can literally be a small caching
difference at this point
because
I think the caching makes more of a
difference than anything. So, relatively
small differences in how this is put
together are going to make diff like
decent differences in Perf. We should
get GPU bound anyways. So, that's
probably what we should focus on. I
think I'm at least satisfied that we
have some better understanding.
Let me use the restroom real quick.
Maybe grab myself a mug of tea. I'm
going to be a few minutes and then we're
going to start on the next segment. I'm
live all day. I'm only an hour and a
half in. This is like minimum minimum
eight hour stream today.
No clue. Would have to look at it. It's
on GitHub. It's kind of on GitHub.
Actually, I think that the version on
GitHub is reasonably clean. Let me link
you this uh and I'll be back in a few.
I think this is relatively good. I
haven't committed a mess to this, have
I?
C thread stuff. Yeah. So, there are a
couple different backends here. Probably
we're only going to have like a simple
OM one by the end of this. So, this is
more complicated than it's going to be.
But the idea is this end binding file
plus this veend header that's in here
get compiled
uh as a single shared library. with each
different
uh each different of these environment
binding files like this is an
environment binding file and then you
get a shared library for loading that
end. I'll link you it and I'll be right
I'll be right back. Let me grab a mug of
tea and we'll keep going.
So,
first thing
We are exporting
way too much crap.
Hey, hey, Liberty.
We've been checking on vectorization
performance and we're going to start
just massively cleaning up puffer today.
I don't like this macro.
I can actually get Claude to clean
things up here if I But I want more
control. So, I think we're going to do
it this way.
Just want to make sure that we're doing
what I think we're doing.
Docker just to stop dropping GPUs.
That's super annoying.
I don't think I have anything super
crucial on here.
It'll come back up in a second, though.
It should at least. It'll be very
unfortunate if it doesn't.
I do have somebody who can turn the
machine back on there if it doesn't.
That's a very
error. I have not had to reboot that
machine in a long time.
I had that on both of my machines today,
which leads me to suspect there was like
some weird system thing.
That's such a weird thing. I would think
Elon would understand that given he
plays a ton of games. That's just like
not how it works, dude.
Oh, come on. Come back on machine. I'll
give it a minute.
That's going to suck if that does not
come back up, though.
So basically the plan is at the moment
um
we make sure that the new end thing is
faster. I'm almost sure it is. We strip
out all the old redundant tests
because they're also exporting a bunch
of symbols. It's doing weird things as
well.
Um
we profile
GPU transfer bandwidth.
We have the main of popular lib C++ and
modules and stuff to clean up.
We start trying to get all of our
performance tests aggregated into one
nice spot so we can get all of our
performance tests in just like one nice
suite.
Is this machine really not going to come
back up?
Like
what is going on? Why do I had Why did I
have both of my machines do this today?
Oh, no. It did. It came back up.
Good.
Yay.
I don't have to get distracted by random
[ __ ]
Good.
28 mill.
Huh.
When I tested this before, it was a huge
difference.
I don't think drive works with this
either.
So, I guess I have to keep both back
ends.
This deck stuff is so jank.
So incredibly jank.
We have we still have too much stuff.
So like they just clean stuff up. Stuff
in general is still the right thing.
Just that there's also some annoying
testing.
It's fine.
It
reset.
I actually like that as an interface
much more.
I I don't think that this like separate
window thing is good.
It should definitely live live in your
editor. The mistake was that that
doesn't mean you need an IDE.
It can live in Bim just fine.
delete a whole bunch of the tests that
we don't need.
Need this.
Don't need this. Yep.
A whole bunch of crap. So, yeah, this
will be cleaned up. I mean, this is all
just like deleting Claude's crap in the
first place.
So, we do use this to write a bunch of
throwaway tests. Now we delete the
throwaway test and we end up with the
newly optimized version of the code that
I actually wrote
which is good.
Yeah. Get rid of the P threading crap.
And then it should end up deleting some
tests from test unfin.
Yep. So, we don't want any of these
inner loop functions exposed.
Uh, I'm pretty sure that means they
don't get inlined.
There's some optimizations the compiler
can't make if you expose everything like
this.
Now, I'm confused because I thought this
was way faster than the previous imple.
It also doesn't work with drive, so
we're going to have to figure that out.
We'll consider this simultaneously part
of the cleanup for um ends binding as
well as some of the testing. I do not
want to be working on just end binds all
day, though. I really want to have like
at least a good three, four hours to
just clean up as a whole.
because we're no longer exposing the
functions we need for this, which is
good. This was like a mega test, which
was bad. A lot of the compile stuff we
were doing would actually mess this up.
And hopefully we can run clean version
of test with the same result or slightly
better.
All right. So now,
oops. Go back. Break out.
And we do
Direct. Can we do this?
Oh, I guess we can.
step direct. Oh, no. This is fine
because it just calls. Yeah, this is
totally fine because it's still a back
function.
55.
That's slow.
Now I think we have the device transfers
wrong here.
So
the idea is
the actions are going to be put on GPU
but we don't know what stream
style nets
puffer and each end ports that one
symbol
but I define a single puffer end API
and each end exports that one symbol and
have a version check
how do you do that
wait exports that what one symbol
so
things that I need from the environment
right um
you need to have the
there's a step function there's a reset
function there's like a close function
there's a render function so there are a
few functions the binding files like
those the shared function and the init
function uh it's for passing args to the
DLL.
The shared one is because sometimes you
need to pass shared info to all the
copies.
If you have a thing that you think is
cleaner though, I'd be very very happy
to take a look at it because I mean in
my mind it's very important that this
thing end up being nice and clean.
And it's not even that much work if I
have to refactor 20 m worth to it
because it's basically automatic now.
So this is what we want. We pass to
stream key t synchronize stream no
device synchronizes
be very good
and make sure it doesn't mess up.
Yes.
No, that's fine.
Hot reloading. The host owns the state
block.
engine runs and can just load the game.
Wait, wait. For hot reloading, the host
owns the state block.
So, the engine runs and can just load
the game DL.
I think the application is a bit
different here.
Let me think.
Well, we're not really trying to do hot
reloading in that way.
Um, I think we do own the state block,
right? because like for the vectorzed
init
we create um a big array of ends
and I think that's done on host
assuming you mean host process not host
like the CPU
you want to avoid the torch Yeah, I
don't want to have to like do the big
heavy compilation for everything. I
mean, I wouldn't have this problem
otherwise. So, it's I don't want the
torch compilation for this, but also I
don't want to have to like I guess we
could technically just rely on caching
for all the other ends, but I don't want
to have to include all the environments
every time you build the train loop,
right? Every time you build training,
you just should be able to build the 1M
load unload. Yeah, we are not looking to
load unload while running. I mean our
game builds in some sense like the
standalone build for the games is it's
instantaneous anyways.
I guess technically we could do hot
reload for like the dev loop a little
bit. Might be okay.
Null is default stream.
That's fine then.
Okay, they're the same speed now at
least. Uh, the OM one doesn't fall,
which is nice.
Cool.
So, we need to queue up um action
transfer, don't we?
Because the idea is
we get OBS.
There's one spot we definitely have. We
have to synchronize a couple things, but
I don't think we need to synchronize
everywhere.
It's actually the OM is so much easier
to think about. So you run your net,
right?
Yeah, we we want these streams to be
I see what's wrong. Okay.
Now, where's our We have the OM
function, don't we?
Yeah. Back OM step here.
did not update the uh
Yeah, it didn't update the OMP
I also think we can just make this be
the same stream.
That would be really cool, right? If we
just have Twerk be on the same stream.
I think that's what it's going to end up
being.
Yeah, that'll be so much better. Right.
So, imagine then we have the network.
You can do that, right? You just call.
Yeah, you can totally do that.
Uh, I didn't know you could do that.
Cool.
I guess also papa it can you tell me
there's so everything that you export
right the compiler can't inline
does it make sense to have wrapper
functions for stuff like let's say if I
want to have the single end of step
function right so that gets called in a
a tight loop so you want that to be
inlined
um but like let's say you also want want
to be able to call it directly. Should I
like should I essentially wrap it and
then expose the wrapped version so that
the original still gets inlined
cuz there's definitely compiler
shenanigans going on here and I'm
getting perf degradations behind the
shared barrier
version size to API struck and you
validate that it matches which is
standard to not [ __ ] something up. Okay,
that's actually really cool. I just see
I didn't know that. That's nice.
That is nice.
Yeah, we are definitely very loose
around um
like that type of stuff here for sure
cuz we I like I just maintain so much of
this stuff. I kind of just fix a lot of
things manually.
That's definitely a good thing to do
though.
This guy will grow a reasonable sense of
humor in a couple of years.
I am curious. Do you like learn stuff
while you're here?
Because presumably you come to like this
specific text stream for some reason.
I do that too since pointer call from
loaded so can never be inlined.
Yeah. Okay. Well, that's easy to do
though at the very least and that's like
a one time
start freelancing in back end. Good
luck.
for company and to ask annoying
questions.
I don't want anything just play the
stream in the background.
Well, there is some cool dev going on
here.
I mean, this is actually the fastest
the fastest thing out there in RL by
quite a wide margin.
Not to mention, we do have better
algorithms and like some pretty unique
tech as well in here, not just faster.
Okay, so
here's what I'm thinking. Can we run the
policy
Jax. It's slower. We're faster. Our code
is simpler
and faster and scales better. Jax is
trolling.
People like Jax because like
it is it makes it very easy to get kind
of okay PF,
but it's at the price of not being able
to really write interesting ends, having
to write absolutely insane code. Uh that
is essentially a DSL of Python.
Uh it obscures a lot of stuff. It makes
really serious performance optimization
almost impossible.
Uh, and it adds a bunch of compile
overhead. It's just a bad fall
everywhere.
How does nin GPU work in GPU handle
complex logic and ends? No, GPUs are
terrible at branching logic, which is
why you have all these Jack demos of
like, oh, it's pretty fast for simple MS
if you run 32KMS and have relatively
simple logic and then nobody's done
anything like the complexity of puffer m
that's also fast. The best example out
there is something like fraax which gets
100k steps per second for just the env
and then you've spent your entire GPU
time on the end. You don't have any left
over for training. So, you'll go down to
50k for training. Um,
and the logic for that end is a total
mess. Like, don't get me wrong, the guy
that wrote it is brilliant, but it would
just be dramatically simpler and faster
to do it in C.
GPU stepping. It's not faster because
you're spending your GPU time on a task
that it's not designed for and not on
training as well.
So like if you're simulating Craftex at
100K on GPU, yeah, now you don't have to
move it from the CPU to the GPU. So you
save that, but like your NV is slow. You
could just have it run at millions of
steps per second on the CPU, buffer the
transfers, which is what we're doing
right here, not have very much overhead
on the transfers at all for OBS that
size, and be running at uh training
faster as well.
loops are not crossboundary.
Wait, make two compile options. You can
do static or vtable.
Oops, you're not crossing. You shouldn't
lose much.
Static or the vtable dynamic approach.
I see.
Well, I mean, I can see I'm losing a bit
because I have, you know, I have the
standalone vec and then I have the um I
just like put it behind a shared
library, but I don't know if it's just
cuz I'm exporting too much stuff or if I
have weird flags.
You can probably get 1 mil plus if you
join XAI. Yeah. Or any of the other
labs. I don't want it.
I'm way happier doing this.
I do think that I'm going to be I mean
that this stuff is going to make plenty
of money as well. It's not the primary
objective, but it's a secondary one for
sure.
I mean, we do have active contracts with
um a few different companies. We have a
couple big ones that we're working on
signing Q1 as well.
And then we also get to do all this, you
know, not behind closed doors. Um, in my
mind,
this is an area of science I've invested
a decade of my life into, and I don't
want to see this get moved to behind
closed doors in the big labs. Like, one
of the reasons that I'm making
everything so fast is because once you
can do this on your laptop, and the code
is super simple and relatively new
people can at least get a hang of the
basics of it quite quickly, uh, this
tech will never be lost, right? And it's
incredibly powerful. It's completely
different from what's going on in the
rest of AI.
And I think it's going to be just as
impactful eventually. I think people
will see that.
Working on stable. Yeah, Jess, we are
working on stable alpha, but there are
also some just some weird things going
on with the end bindings.
I to do an LMRL contract a lot because
it's a total distraction.
I also just don't know why you would,
right? like
I don't know. I've had a few different
companies try to including X. Um
like like want to hire me just like as a
generally smart person to go work on
their stuff, but like that's not really
what I'm interested in doing, right? You
know, the stuff that I have here for RL
is really well suited to a specific type
of problem, and there's not really a
point in trying to force it on a
different problem area. Like, yeah, I
could go shift gears and focus on that,
but I'm not really interested in doing
that,
you know?
Okay. So, yeah, now we pass we make our
own streams, right?
And this is good.
Now, we no longer need to Okay, so
essentially what this is now doing is
we're replaying the policy
on the same stream as well.
So as a result, I think we have no more
synchronizations except for the one for
um
obviously we have to sync before we step
the environment because we have to make
sure that we're done computing things on
the GPU and the data is ready.
Let me go see where this is.
agents. Is that more rel? It could be,
but not really.
It's just like that's not really
I honestly don't find those problems
particularly exciting or important.
Like I want this stuff to eventually go
to improving scientific simulation.
All operations
get stream from external
I think that all this is is um wrapping
this as a torch stream.
Oh, wait. Actually, why did you freaking
do this?
They put my profile macros back in
there.
Okay.
And uh put my profile comments back.
It's stuck. Doesn't know whether it's
C10 or AT. I actually don't know either,
though.
I mean, it's very easy to check.
Uhhuh.
Probably forgot to update um back end.
Yeah, the back end call back. No biggie.
Uh I don't know if you can include this
here.
should be compatible. Let's verify.
Yeah. So, we passed void star. So, we
don't have to include that in the back
end.
What six looks like. And no idea what
six looks like. Jess
type. Um,
so I don't think that you're going to
want one physics standard
because Fundamentally, there are
different scales at which you want to
simulate things. And the main sin being
committed by uh numerical sim people is
always trying to make everything as
accurate as possible without regard to
the level of accuracy needed to actually
solve the problem at hand and therefore
making things very slow. So that's
actually the main thing that we don't
want to do.
Now there may end up being commonalities
where we find groups of problems that
can share the same backend. I would not
be surprised
but I don't think that's going to be
like uh that's not going to be the
imperative is like to find that Okay.
Should we wait? Hang on. Let me think.
Should we be simulating a mem copy
or me set?
We should, right?
I mean, that's a very fast off though.
I think this is okay.
Yeah, this is fine.
So this gets a 33.
So now what we can do is we can do
one
Let me see if drive still works on the
old one.
selfplay port to 40.
I don't think it should be hard.
I mean, I have to see what you've done,
right?
like most of the janky stuff that I'm
doing frankly
it's it's at a lower level than is than
your code exists at
like just the um if you just write the
torch C++ API their code's a mess but
the it honestly looks almost the same as
the Python it's not that bad it's when
you're doing like manual CUDA graphing
and custom kernels and modules like
that's when stuff gets fancy and weird.
So just porting some chunks of the
Python to the Torch C++ API will not be
that bad.
Also, there is a Python compatible
version like Puffer 4 is not going to be
C++ only. We will have Python exports
for stuff but we're going to do it at
various levels right so like for
instance you'll be able to call our
graph forward paths uh as one C++ call
or you can do it more granular.
We're going to basically have it so that
all of our optimized chunks get
exported.
You can also just write normal torch and
it'll work right. It's just that our
stuff is so nicely optimized. Like when
everything is so fast, almost anything
that you do that is not optimized, like
you'll see a good dip in SPS.
You know, you'll add like one random
tour drop and you'll lose 10% each.
This is what it takes to make stuff
fast.
Ah, yes. I see this is correct.
Just a minor indexing bug.
Talk to Spencer about it. Let me see the
complex thing. Apparently pull on GPU
and standby on CPU too to avoid the
delay uploading models.
That's fine.
Why do you even have to offload them,
man? The models are tiny. No, it's a few
megabytes per model. How many models do
you have?
Oh, wait. That's 1.46 mil on uh on GPU,
isn't it?
Dota does not tap the pool.
Okay, fair.
Look at that. It's a bit faster.
That's nice.
We run CPU
a 1.7 mil throughput
So 2.19 on CPU back
and then if I do
Okay, I think I'm happy enough to just
like keep this.
Is there anything else I would change
with this?
It's just a bunch of synchronization
overhead, right?
Chess is going to be so good
uh once that project is like fully
mature
because we need more of these really
hard environments that you have log
linear perf on, right? Because like we
essentially we want a bunch of
environments that are really stable that
have log linear perf with compute under
optimized settings so that when we make
algorithmic changes and like we can
essentially just test does this change
the learning curve of these really hard
environments.
in nfbinding.h
there's redundant device sync.
Yes. So uh that's what I'm messing with
right now. Let me show you why that's
there.
So in the version I'm working on if we
go where is it back receive
wait they already call sync before
returning and after host device
so this is I now it's changed to extreme
synchronize
So the issue that I had uh the reason
that there were synchronizes here before
um
we essentially we didn't know what
stream torch was on right so torch would
give you back actions
but you wouldn't know what stream so you
had to sync the entire device in order
to make sure that you had the actions
computed before you could then move them
on a different stream to the CPU. view.
Uh now what we're doing is we're just
setting the uh the stream of the model
itself and they're going to we should be
able to remove pretty much all these
synchronizes.
Yeah,
actually, thank you for drawing my
attention to this because I think
actually this one as well probably since
now if the models are on the same
stream, right, we actually don't need to
explicitly do as many synchronizes
because it just won't ceue up ops out of
order.
Why would there algorithm that log
linear?
What types of patterns are you hoping to
get? Uh just ELO curves are typically
log linear with compute
right
like the Dota ELO curve for instance is
log linear with compute most of these
projects have ELO curve log linear with
compute
the thing is ELO itself like skill is
exponential in some sense so it's not
like log linear is not bad in that case,
but we might end up being able to do
better out like with different
algorithms
either by like a very large constant
factor or some problem or by some factor
that scales with some other aspect of
the problem. I think ELO is probably
still going to be log linear in some
sense, but like there might be other
aspects of the problem that you can
remove that scaling from.
Come on. Come on. Come on. Give me
signature update. I'm going to remove
these syncs and we'll continue from
there.
Okay. So, this is good. So, we can do
this. Oops.
that I get over there when we get there.
Yes, we do. For five, we do not for six
yet. I have one version out, Jess. There
are two different things around
exploration that I think are like not
[ __ ] and actually likely to work.
Actually, um
I'm going to be playing uh I've got like
a game session with uh a couple RL
researchers I know that do exploration
stuff. We might even stream it for the
hell of it uh this weekend. We'll say
after my Saturdays for
Like you play games. I don't stream them
normally, but uh I mean it's four RL
researchers hanging out playing a game
and probably chatting about a couple
research things. So we might I mean they
like one of them suggested it so I'm
considering it.
What do I play? Uh me personally, I've
just been playing a bunch of Runescape
in the evenings. I uh I downloaded that
game after three years off,
but you know, Puffer is in a good spot
and I figure I can have some I get to
enjoy my game a little bit again. Uh but
then we're probably going to be playing
Baron. It's like this rogike uh dungeon
crawler game that's very similar to Net
Hack and both of them do research on Net
Hack.
Does it need to sync before we log?
Maybe
it might need to synchronize before we
log.
Yeah.
Try this real quick.
No. H.
Should I add automatic domain
randomization or should I should keep
the same difficulty of training
the entire run?
You can try adding it. It's a little bit
tricky though.
Automatic. It's complexity. So you can
make it work but it's not an out of the
box thing. Um
it I guess it what it depends on is it
depends on the magnitude of the gap uh
in complexity from the start to the end
of training. Like if I wanted to go from
size five to size 1,000 mazes for
instance, I'd probably need it
uh in our normal training runs. So you
get a little bit of it for free with the
way that our our prioritize sampling
works.
Like it just automatically prioritizes
high advantage segments. So once it
learns the easy stuff, it'll kind of
just start dropping it for you from the
training batches and it will focus on
optimizing the harder ones a little bit.
But if the magnitude of that effect is
too big, then our implementation will
break down and you would need something
more dedicated for the stuff you're
doing. I'd be pretty surprised if it's
required.
So steps,
you might just be sampling at too high
frequency. Frankly, that's like a common
gotcha.
Like training at very high time
frequency just creates these really
annoying extended credit assignment
horizons. It's actually most of the time
it's not the episode length, it's the
number of steps between rewards, if that
makes sense. So like having 100,000 step
uh episodes is totally fine or never
resetting is fine if you're getting
rewards every few dozen steps or every
hundred steps even sometimes, right?
But now if if the environment is
changing a lot such that it looks very
different at the end of the episode
versus the start that's different
mostly dense
then episode length itself is not a
problem per se.
Presumably you have dense rewards in a
way that's reasonable like the delta
base rewards instead of the um the
constant rewards. That's a common
gotcha.
It's already set up as deltas in the
drone end from poper fuse that as a
starting point. Uh what else?
Yeah, I that should mostly be fine. The
other thing is um really long episodes
if you're getting heterogeneous
data. Uh you do want to have all your
episodes offset. So if they're the exact
same amount of time and they're really
long, you know, you're going to get a
batch of data from the start, then a
batch of data from the middle, a batch
of data from the end. That's bad. So,
you want to at least randomize the
offsets of all the different ends. Those
are a couple of common gotchas.
That's funny.
Stupid
randomizing offsets. Yeah, it's just a
common gotcha environment changing
just to make makes the start more
difficult after it's table be solved
could be
I mean what we do is our sampling it
grabs batches of data with a high
absolute advantage so as long as you
have a decent amount of signal in each
batch it'll go grab the high signal
batches so like a lot of the instability
is kind of handled for you in that sense
it's one of our actually our key
algorithmic improvements that we made uh
with Puffer Great.
It's fine.
Randomize the offset. Uh so for really
long games, if there's a timeout, for
instance, like let's say every game
times out at 300 steps. So like it's
always 300 steps. Then you want to start
off some like you want to start the M's
off as at random times just for the
first iteration so that they get um you
know they they get all offset from each
other so that you get data from the
start, middle and end in every single
epoch.
Kind of insane how stable puffer is.
It's going to get better too. We have
11.8 million step per second training in
dev now. And uh I think we can get it
even a little bit faster. That's still
in FP32.
We haven't even done Bflat yet.
We have uh like a brand new architecture
for Puffer 4. We've got some sweep
improvements. We've got new environment
backend vectorzation.
Uh we're going to do constellation. I
still have to finish, but it's like
large scale experiment visualization
stuff, which is nice.
But the main thing is just everything is
so low overhead now that your typical
breakout experiment that we use as a
test case is going to be about 3 to 4x
faster than it was in Puffer 3. But then
there are going to be several
configurations uh of training that you
might want to run that would just be,
you know, 20x plus faster than Puffer 3
because we've cut down overhead, right?
So anything that was like uh really
strongly dependent on the torch overhead
is now going to be way faster. Now
bigger nets like bigger uh bigger
networks are going to benefit less which
is why we also want to get bloat 16 in
because at least then there will be one
major improvement for these ms but I
think like pretty much everything will
at least see some reasonable benefit.
Had this problem early on in chess
solved itself but I wish I knew back
then. Yeah, it's a common gotcha.
RL pros messed this thing up too. One of
my buddies, Don, wrote a paper about
this, like, "Hey, all you roboticists
are trolling. You're just all screwing
this thing up." It was pretty funny.
Yeah,
dev loop's important. Okay, this is only
10 five, so I don't know where our perf
went.
Should be 11. Oh. Uh, our vec back end
obviously, right?
Yeah. So, VEC back end should do it.
Deploying 10 miles an hour.
Yeah.
Holy [ __ ]
Okay. It's not stable. It's not stable.
Never mind. We're probably just skipping
a synchronization.
If this is real and like we just have a
bug, 14 mil would be pretty cool. I
don't think so though. I don't think
this is real.
That would be pretty cool.
Uh, let me go grab a new mug of tea and
then we'll figure out if uh if we
actually get 14 mil or not. I don't
think there was that much overhead in
the end in the first place, but maybe. I
don't know. Maybe we have different
torch streams now. Who knows? I'll be
right back.
Sweep.
What's this?
Sometimes even as high as a certain
amount of e box.
Yeah, you sweep.
That's it.
So you need this synchronize.
No sync here.
We're going to try adding a couple
synchronizes
just because like something's great.
Oops.
It's probably something done with the um
the streams, wouldn't you think?
Maybe this the followup call is not
being on the same stream. No, but
because then the thing is that would
have been solved by the uh
the synchronize that I put in.
That should have been solved
on a different stream than what we're
using. They are being it said that was
fine.
Maybe not though.
don't start separate streams before
tracing
current stream.
No, it makes a capture stream
specifically.
All custom kernels need to use the
default torch stream.
Wait, all custom colonels need to use
the default torch stream. Oh, hang on.
Hang on.
Port stream functions, not the C10 ones.
It's probably that
get current CUDA stream. That's actually
fine if it gets set.
That's from back reset though.
That gets synchronized.
I think that's fine.
So let's just go full
false
Yeah, this trains.
Okay, so it is actually something with
um
wraps or whatever.
That's what we want out of a learning
curve. Look at that.
shared RNG offset tensor.
I don't think that's it.
I because it's also screwed up with just
pudraphs, right?
Make sure using stream function, not
C10.
Jesus,
what the [ __ ]
I have the alarm literally. It's right
above my desk there.
Can't hear anything out of my right ear.
Yeah, this is what we want.
Now we match this function at least.
course, it could be two different
things.
Probably it's two different things,
right?
No, actually, it could just both be that
cuz it's not setting the stream
correctly. That would totally do it.
That's not a quick enough learning
curve.
It's interesting. It's learning some
stuff,
but um
not quite there.
health to fitness. I have several
articles just
Does this still work with um
does it still work in this mode?
Hey Peru,
your VEC has worked very well. We're
actually I'm integrating one additional
thing with it now and I'm trying to get
it to work which is um we're trying to
have the porch model be on the same
stream as uh the end buffer so that we
don't need to sync.
Okay. Yeah, this still works.
That was one of the things you did,
right? It's like you made it so that the
net call and the uh the end buffers and
everything like if you have two buffers,
it's two different streams, right?
Huffer stream and the network as well
right was on the same stream.
Yes. Okay.
Something real quick.
We're getting like crazy 14 15 SPS but
it's broken at the moment and I don't
actually know whether um that would seem
high to me. I don't think we can
actually get that high. So I think this
is just bugged. I have confirmed that
the implementation works though. The
11.8 number is real.
Let me just boot a device synchronize
real quick. Before and after.
Yeah. So, that was a very big
contribution.
Um, I want to see actually how big it is
with the streams. That's the next thing
I'm interested to uh
to figure out here.
Open MP just had too much magic.
She wrote the smallest version of it. I
tried doing that and I couldn't get it
to match perk with open MP.
I didn't like this. I didn't like the
C++ here.
I wanted to keep I wanted to keep the
threading back and just C.
That was the main thing with this. I
have been reading this though for
reference. Like I've been reading this
and trying to take the techniques.
Yeah, I actually I really want to
minimize the C++ surface. I hate the
torches in C++. Their C++ is absolutely
terrible.
uh like minimal really simple C as much
as possible is what we're trying to get.
It's really not even that bad. I
actually end up doing pretty much the
same thing as you do here. Like I just
pass one void uh one void pointer for
the network.
Let me see if this did anything. Oh,
wait. This trains
like an intro guide or do you already?
Uh, you really don't need an intro guide
from me, Jess. You just go grab strong
list or go grab a pair of running shoes.
It's that simple.
Buffing with train LSTM math Python. So
the LSTM arch doesn't paralyze over time
at train. Yo, you missed my question.
Oh, I should be manually resetting the
LSTM state at the end of each game
during rollouts for chess in puff.
Manually resetting. This is one of the
things we kind of punted on Spencer.
uh we just don't reset at the moment
except between
at the moment we are resetting between
epochs which is probably the wrong thing
to be doing and probably just by messing
around with when state is reset we can
probably get a lot of perf on the few
ends
That would maybe make sense.
I'll play with that. Yeah, this is like
one of the things we definitely need to
mess with. I messed with it for a client
and it does make a difference at one
point, but like it also can mess stuff
up, right? because it can let you
metalarn across rollouts, which I
remember with a drive end, right? It
would metalarn like um it would get to
the goal once and then it would just go
straight there because it would know
where it is every time.
That was one of the big bugs we had.
resetting on crap.
Yeah, it can it could that's reasonable.
I would think that resetting the state
is like uh less important than keeping
the state across boundaries,
but I don't know.
Does Tim does not favor women?
I think so. Peru, we need to run all the
experiments.
I mean, if you get it really fast, then
sure, but like you can't paralyze the
training is the issue.
So it basically it forces you to have
really big batches, really big mini
batches or really short horizons because
you can't paralyze the time dim at all.
So it's like it's not always bad, but it
does restrict it restricts what you can
do. Can you paralyze? You can't paralyze
grew, but you can paralyze min. It's a
different architecture. There's also a
min LSTM.
Uh it lets you paralyze not the full
thing, but the like the gate is still
not parallel, but the map mole is
parallel. So you can batch all the mat
moles
giving these [ __ ] money. I don't
know. Is Gemini any good?
It's kind of sad that I think my least
like the least bad of them is Google at
the moment in terms of people I want I
am happy giving money to
credit bill is probably going to be uh
lower once I finish the refactor.
Google's world model. No.
Is it not all over timeline?
It just needs to go. Wait, it's here,
right?
It's just not doing the roll out on
this. Yeah. Okay, we're done.
Did that just break it?
Hang on. Did that break it or am I
No, it's it's it has to go here, right?
used in any food stream
except the null stream.
Except the null stream.
They have it here or here is my
question.
It's got to be something with the stream
set
open model 90% of what Claude does. 7x
cheaper. Eh,
wait. What do you mean the same guys
that did Mu on it? Did Keller? Isn't it
open AI?
and we have the clues in front of us,
Amen.
Trying to catch up on the stuff.
Have an SD leave for in June 5 days.
That's cool. I'm still in Florida. And
otherwise, I would have been happy to
chat like to be there in person, but I
ended up only being in uh California for
like a couple days on the way to a
vacation and a couple days on the way
back. I was barely there at all.
The first to use it
speedun guys were the first to do stuff,
right? Keller with his speed run.
Buffer got there pretty quick as well on
on RL. I think we were definitely the
first um for this type of work, the
first to adopt.
It took a full hyper like reweep was the
funny thing.
Why is it like this? Right. Why is it
like this?
It doesn't even does it work with one
buffer?
Let's Let's take that out as a
possibility, right?
move back to Kelly depending
be there most of the time.
Tennessee and Kentucky.
Yeah. Best of luck with all that stuff,
man. That's no fun.
The one clip,
the QK clip.
Wait, QK clip. Does that do something
for us?
That doesn't do anything for us, right?
It's like for attention specifically.
Okay.
Open. Wait.
I mean, I might just I might play around
with switching it at some point. Just
like set up open what is it? Open
something or other
open code.
Maybe just explicitly call the CUDA
function instead of the torch function.
Nvidia just doesn't have a neural net
library, right? They don't even have one
that's like good but not popular.
I mean really this like the these things
are not that big of a deal at the
moment.
You might hallucinate.
Why you consider me to do the
unimportant stuff?
Yeah, but like you're doing chess stuff
and chess is way more important than
that.
Like chess is actually a really awesome
end.
Rodel craps.
You don't need this, do you?
At CUDA. Okay. So, this is a torch
graph, isn't it?
Copy calls do need to be on the right
stream, which is why we have it set.
I'm confused by freaking being crap is
what it is.
We We're already setting the stream,
dude.
No, this is fine.
Is it stream in this context? Uh it's a
CUDA thing, man. So you have multiple
streams to the GPU
and ops can happen on different streams.
So when you synchronize, you can either
synchronize the entire GPU or you can
synchronize a specific stream. So Torch
doesn't expect you to screw with this.
But if you're doing buffered rollouts
like we are and you put them on
different streams entirely, you can
avoid a bunch of redundant
synchronization and save time.
But Torch doesn't make that easy because
they expect you to be an idiot and only
touch their high level API and have
everything be slow.
Choose CS stream, sir.
What do you mean? What made me choose CS
stream? I'm just dreaming my work, man.
This is my normal work.
Are they going to do this crap again
with the Hang on, let me mute this.
Hopefully not. I'm going to be pissed if
they are
Does this work scale to a large skill
training or is it mostly designed
skill? Well, the thing is like you can
literally do with puffer on one GPU what
you used to need a thousand for. So
yeah, we literally train on more data
than OpenAI does on one JPU.
It's a very different type of scale.
Like this work is not being held back by
not scaling to a bunch of hardware,
though we can run it on multiple GPUs.
Uh it's scaled back by everybody being
absolutely terrible at engineering.
What made you tilt to CS?
Uh, I mean, machine learning was really
just taking off when I was considering
what to do. It was always going to be
some sort of science or research.
And, uh, lab science felt very
restrictive
in some sense.
You know, you can do a heck of a lot.
You don't need a bunch of equipment. You
can do a heck of a lot. Uh work can move
very fast if you're good. Just a lot of
things AI has going for it.
It wasn't just CS. It was already AI
when I was
doing this.
It was already quite specific.
No, this doesn't train. It's not fast
enough. We'll see.
Yeah, I trained some, but
there's something synchronization
Does Peru have this
working with torch?
Oh no, he doesn't because he doesn't
have pers.
Yeah, he probably doesn't have pers.
Okay, if he didn't solve this, I have to
solve this. Damn it.
Okay, let's see if it's the last one.
And then
we can get rid of this device if I
synchronize.
stupid cuda graphs, man. This is
literally just porch being crap.
So obnoxious.
I did have trouble syncing streams
regardless of graphs or not.
Okay.
Wait for streams to synchronize before
yielding to train.
Yeah, I it's not enough before yielding
to train. It's every iter. Okay, it is
the it is the default stream though.
This confirms it.
Somehow something's getting launched on
default stream.
One sec.
It works with if it works with default
stream. I'm wondering if you need torch
guard to know which stream the level API
may not stream guard. This whole torch
is a mess. It is. It's a total mess. And
it's be it's Torch's fault as well cuz
they have wrappers for everything.
And you don't know what like which
things are compatible or not.
No, this is not. We're not taking this
perfect. So,
I tried using the raw API. I think that
their rappers do some stuff they rely
on. This is why it's such a mess.
I think that you're right that
eventually the goal is to just use the
raw raw graphs.
I'm pretty sure you don't want to have
these guards, but we can try this.
I think we still have the um the sinks
in here, don't we?
We still have the sinks in here. So,
don't get excited yet.
If I can remove the sinks,
then we have something.
It's not the same,
dude. How is this thing freaking
happening? It's like
still on the freaking default stream
somehow.
replay
goes on the current stream as
well.
It's weird.
We can try this
capture perf trace to see which streams
get scheduled. I could probably set
that.
I don't have all that in set up at the
moment.
Torch is just like
so freaking bad, man.
I honestly think you could replace Torch
and like I think you could write a
2,000line library.
Uh, that would be faster and save you
more time than Torch does.
I've spent hundreds of hours of my life
dealing with this piece of crap in the
last few months.
do it. See, the problem is if you don't
have torch bindings, nobody uses your
code because everybody wants freaking
torch
I think what's going to happen is we're
just going to slowly replace everything
that is in torch and then it'll just be
Yeah, it's bound to torch but it's
actually all just puffer code.
I don't get it, man. Look at this. It's
still
If you don't sync the default stream, it
still breaks. I don't understand how.
Async has to use the current stream,
right?
Okay, this actually breaks now again.
That's bad.
There's something going on here.
absolutely
infuriating.
Dude, this [ __ ] garbage code base. I
swear.
not what I wanted to be spending my day
doing.
More [ __ ] torch things.
Meta engineers.
did they break the network?
No. Okay, good.
Now it doesn't work without photographs.
Lovely.
This is [ __ ]
Complete utter [ __ ]
rapper is using some other streams. I
think so. I don't know.
Yeah. Now all of a sudden nothing works.
I don't even know what the heck possibly
changed.
I'm pretty sure we have this exact same
thing that we had before.
stream pointer. It should be. Yeah,
I mean I could be screwing that up, I
suppose. Well, now literally nothing
works even with a device synchronized.
So I broke something Oops.
I'm honestly wondering the extent to
which we even want fortune here. It's so
bad.
I think I'm going to have to content
myself to like only partially be
replacing torch
for this update. But like holy hell, I
don't understand.
Stream pointer. I'm going to have to
check that in a second.
Well, I actually don't even know how
nothing works all of a sudden cuz I'm
pretty sure I didn't change anything.
Let's do this the same way we were doing
it before.
So in capture
graph
we do get stream right
get stream from pool
No.
Huh?
Claw's going to be fired.
It's a [ __ ]
Yeah, we have to go back a whole bunch
of code versions. This is just a
complete unmitigated disaster.
This just drives me absolutely insane.
Okay, so we're going to do
current stream is get current stream.
[ __ ]
work. Wow.
Is this even the right
torch cours?
This has to be it.
But then it says there this thing has a
dot stream, right?
Port stream. So CUDA Cuda stream.
No, this is stream not CUDA stream.
Jesus.
Okay. Whoa. stream
and then they have ah because of course
they do
I don't understand how this just
randomly stopped working on like
literally anything.
So frustrating, man. Why do the torch
devs have to wrap literally everything
they touch? They can't use a goddamn
single thing from anywhere without
adding three additional layers of
[ __ ] minimum.
Whatever. Their code sucks anyways. I'm
sick of dealing with them.
I'm like honestly just so frustrated
with how bad this library is. I cannot
believe that this is what we all use.
And then some [ __ ] would say, "Oh,
use Jack," which is just even worse.
It's like cutting your nose off to spite
your face.
You have net call back.
Do I have net call back commented out?
How
did Opus do that or did I do that?
Dude, I must have like autofilled that
or something.
Okay. Well, thank you, Peru. I'm losing
my mind here, apparently.
right?
Yes.
Good.
This one doesn't. Unless it does all of
a sudden.
I did fix one other bug
and stream not stream because it's not a
pointer.
Uh let me check that. Hang on.
Okay, so this is broken. Confirm. So you
should pass.
Hang on.
I think I've just made a mess of this.
I've just gotten so freaking confused.
yeah, because we're passing by buffer
now.
So, you just need the buffer index
anyways.
streams of buffer.
Is this good?
Yeah, but this still is not going to
learn correctly.
One thing I want to play with here.
One thing I want to play with
Okay. So, this does not break it,
right?
Which it shouldn't. We have the sinks in
place.
Just do this
and this. Right.
Call back
after you copy the OBS back async.
Shouldn't the call back wait before it
runs the graph?
Do they copy the It's on the same stream
though, right Peru?
Okay. So, the non-graphed version works
right here with no syncs.
If you cue something up that depends on
an on an ascopy finishing, won't it just
won't it get cued correctly?
I'll try that. I thought that that gets
um my understanding was that if you cue
an operation that affects
like if you cue an async copy and then
you do another op that depends on the
output.
I thought it waits on ops from that
stream to finish because it cues ops in
this stream.
I mean that's easy enough to test. I
just do cuda stream synchronize, right?
before the uh the net call back.
The copies are on the default stream.
Uh, no, wait. The the copy shouldn't be
on the default stream
cuz the copies are in the wrapper, man.
Right. The copies are in the wrapper
right here.
I do need to do roll out roll out copy
call.
Uh, these are all asynchronous copies.
So these should go on the current wrap.
Set the same food stream in the copy
block. I mean in the caller in the for
loop you need to set
where
the callback is around the entire thing,
right? So it should be all ops including
the copy should be on the stream.
the thing that calls the net wrapper
call back. You just set the CUDA stream
in the copy block. I do
This code currently works without graph
turned on.
So if this code works without graphs
turned on
It's not enough to synchronize. Hang on.
Let's double check one thing.
I think you're you can't just
synchronize the stream.
I don't think it's enough to synchronize
just the stream either. I think you have
to synchronize the device,
which is the problem.
If I synchronize the device here, it
works. Meaning something's on the wrong
bloody stream. Still,
syncing the stream should be enough. It
would be if everything was on the
correct stream. But as you can see very
very clearly here if you put it on if
you sync the device here it works. If
you sync the stream it doesn't
So the question is what the hell's on
the wrong stream?
We can go try, I suppose, one other
thing,
which is um
if I put this guy down here.
I don't think that's enough either,
though.
No,
not enough.
Something in the loop is on the wrong
stream.
Is there a reasonable way to set this up
and like
inside this entire thing?
So incredibly disappointing, man,
spending this amount of time on this
crap.
Nope.
Just a copy.
I don't understand how the hell this is
even possible.
We have one buffer, right? This is
actually in a thread.
But we have one buffer for testing
anyways,
right? Yeah. It's not that.
peru is there a reasonably quick way to
do this or not really
God, what happened to the amps? The amps
end, by the way. That was cool.
Fed, I just I have no idea what the
hell's wrong with the cudigraphs here.
Like I have absolutely no idea.
I guess we can try for clues. We can go
um
Yeah, this one still works.
What about Colonel?
What will this give us? This gives us um
stream information, man.
loaded. Okay, let me try. There's one
other thing I want to try because it's
actually breaking even without pudgraph
just with custom kernel. So, I think
that's a hint.
Would have just been better to rewrite
PyTorch Jess pretty damn much.
Uh, yeah, pretty damn much.
worth it. Okay, let me rest real quick.
Let me try a couple things and then if
we don't solve it with that, I'll go
back to this. Let me grab a new mug of
tea as well.
If anybody wants to look at this like
the other the other sign that we have
this is weird is so our kernel's all set
like get current CUDA stream.
I don't know if this off is like not
thread safe or some weird crap. Hey,
talk to you in a bit.
I'll be back. I'm getting new muggy tea.
technically a torch. Dude, I swear
I don't need to have my own tensor
library. I just need to not have this
garbage, you know?
Holy hell.
Like there's got to just be like a no
code written by idiots in in any
dependencies rule. Like holy hell.
It's like so freaking infuriating. I
swear.
If I were an idiot, how would I do this?
I would have some operations that
randomly use the default stream somehow,
even though it shouldn't be possible.
That's what I would do. I'd have some
random stupid operation on the default
stream,
thereby screwing over anything else.
That's what I would do.
What hint do we have? Well, we have to
hint that the kernels
the kernels are putting something on the
default stream, right?
They would have to be
You know what? Why don't we just enable
one kernel? We can just enable one
kernel.
one works, right?
So we do mining
to the gate.
Figure out what is on the stupid.
Yes,
this one works. And there's only certain
furnace.
Screw it up.
It's only certain kernels that screw it
up. Very good.
What about this one? This one has a back
patch to it.
This one also doesn't seem to break
anything.
That's interesting.
Okay.
It's very interesting. Yes.
Uh, did I just do what I think I just
did?
Did I just type true or kernels like
this and have it not compile and not
notice?
What does he have? Does it have that?
What?
I'm shocked. I I don't understand.
Whatever.
How about this?
And we did actually compile, right?
Yeah, this compiles.
It's faster, too, isn't it?
Okay, it's not that one.
This is going to drive me absolutely
insane.
This is the one that breaks. Really?
The one that's not even in the call
back?
Really?
Yeah. Somehow the current not even part
of this
is uh breaking it.
No, not enough.
Lovely.
I don't even know how this is [ __ ]
possible at this point, man.
I truly don't understand.
I'm not I'm not dealing with their crap,
man.
The kernels were optimizing have direct
use in RO.
Okay. So if you add a device synchronize
here
then it still works with the kernels.
What does that mean?
Which means if I do what is it back?
If I do this, it should also work,
right?
Yeah.
Okay. So,
Put something on the background quiet to
I don't know.
The only difference with the kernels,
right,
they cue on the current stream.
per stream per se.
So, um Peru right now I have one buffer
per testing.
I already isolated that.
So there I actually don't know what he
looks like. So probably
cuz I only know it's like his picture
from that he was on Dota, right? So
probably
I actually can't see what's wrong with
this.
You set the current stream
in the thread.
Actually, the kernels thing is not a
problem. Right.
Come to think of it, like this is
totally fine, isn't it?
Oh, wait. Really?
Hang on. Maybe maybe it's not fine.
I thought I fixed this.
Okay. I mean, we still don't have the
clue.
So specifically this kernel screws it
up.
This one should work.
Yeah, this one works, right? Of course,
this one works. Now, we do
does this not use?
It uses the same freaking data.
Convert environment
ocean folder loans pre-trains weights.
So the training code is just popper lib
like puffer lib puffer route.
The C file is just for demo. The
environment code is in the.h training is
in puffer puffer docs or puffer.ai the
website.
Well, at least I'm not going completely
insane. It is a stream thing because if
you set default streams, everything
works.
And if I just do this
I do have it to get current, not
default, right?
No,
it's always get current.
Let's just make sure we're passing the
right thing.
I'm going to go absolutely insane with
this.
This is just
like why
Oh,
wait.
Yeah. No, this is fine.
I just don't understand how this is so
messed up.
This is default stream.
It's all correct.
The fact that it's not it doesn't work
with a device sync
with this custom kernel is really weird,
right?
I mean Wait, how the hell is that even
possible? Right.
We have to find like some hypothesis
that fits this, I think, because I don't
understand how this is possible.
Like this one kernel.
Yeah.
So, here's the question.
How on earth does it work with
everything except this kernel here?
This kernel works fine without on this
the default stream. This kernel works
fine. So, the ops are correct.
Wait, what the heck even possibly fits
this, right?
Cuz the data that's coming into this has
to be correct.
Did I check the wrong one?
Cuda stream t get current CUDA stream
gets passed.
Get current to stream
stream gets passed.
I
have no words.
Did you have any thoughts in end
question something
Um,
I mean the only thing I can suggest,
Jess, is like our new network
architecture probably scales better with
more params, but it's hard to say. Like
I have to run the experiments.
default. It's definitely default CUDA
stream.
I like I actually just have no idea
remotely how on earth
this is being like this.
Wait, what? Chess work linear
fun with half
kingentric.
I bet the zero thought is not on the
stream.
Stockfish run Stockfish's neural net.
They use the fact that it's mirrored and
some other tricks to get super fast
speeds.
I am just baffled right now.
was like bizaro.
I mean, this seems insane to me, but
like
I I don't understand how there is
something not synced.
Hey Sam, organizing our news AI summit.
Want to do an online talk? Sure,
I think that's what it has to be. It's
some part of the policy.
in DMs. Sounds good. Yeah, I'm fighting
Cuda, man. Today has been a rough.
No, it's not only with CUDAs. Oh, what
the hell are you?
O X1.
It's on Ox1. How in the actual hell
is this on a different stream?
I'm so freaking confused how this
happens. This got to be what's happening
everywhere, though.
You know, it's just like sticking my
stuff on a random stream.
Unless I've just messed up. Do I have to
do stream?
So hefty buffer 5 is not going to be
this size update. If I do something else
this size again for the next update, I'm
going to go insane.
All right, that's
See if it's synchronizing before this
works.
We'll isolate.
I wonder if I'm launching the advantage
on the wrong stream.
That would be weird.
I could see that.
H.
Okay, Joseph is confused.
There's a rough combination of stuff
going on here.
I could add a single device think at the
start of the loop. Yeah,
I will I will check that.
Oh, this breaks.
See this? This breaks.
So, this is outside the loop.
Let me try this and then I'll try your
hypothesis.
No, it's not this.
It's not the advantage function.
This would do it right because we don't
use the other graphs or we shouldn't be
using the other graphs
outside of this
Oo,
good call.
I think you're right.
Yeah, I think you're right.
Let's see.
Okay, so now we have this one on.
Huh.
Can we do cudigraph?
We can do pudoggrams.
Can we do buffers?
All right, Peru. You've done Yep. Yep.
Thank you.
I'm exhausted. I'm not thinking
straight.
You're totally right. I I don't know how
I didn't catch that.
had the same problem as I did the native
crane.
I don't know how I screwed that up, man.
That was very dumb.
I just kind of assumed I wouldn't screw
that up. Like,
Okay, you don't need these sinks in
anymore. This is still good. It's 11.2.
Uh, where's our 11.8?
You need the second
batches in parallel within a horizon.
We're doing that. That was the thing
that got me the speed bump from you.
I'm trying to figure out where our speed
went though. It was faster before.
Yeah, that was the main thing I got from
you, man. Was uh was that.
Oh,
I know.
Yeah,
that's 12 mil.
I'm going to make a commit before I mess
this up.
I'm going to rebuild just to make sure I
didn't break it. just like fat fing room
right there.
And then we're going to we're test.
We'll look for a couple extra sync
points. We'll clean some stuff up. I
need to walk around for a few minutes
though. This is just like completely
fried my brain.
I swear when I like I've been live for
seven hours, I just start doing dumb
stuff and missing things.
Wait, didn't we have um
we had 11.8, didn't we? Oh, it was 12
mil.
we're going to do some easier stuff for
a bit. I still need to put more work in
today, but we're going to do some easier
stuff. Let me use the restroom real
quick. Let me walk around. I'm going to
get a little bit more tea.
I think I got a couple hours before
dinner, so we're going to do some stuff
still. I'm going to get a piece of toast
as well. Get a couple calories. And I'm
going to try not to be total goober for
the rest of the day on this cuz there's
a lot of clean up to do still.
Hopefully I will be
less stupid.
slower.
Lovely.
Oh, I might have it hardcoded to a one
map though. Actually,
that might be better than that.
Synchronize the stream at the end.
All these me copies are async.
Same stream.
You know, we can probably just set the
entire stream for this like the stream
for this entire call.
That's a torch thing. Of course, it's a
torch thing. Why would you have one of
these?
Yeah, that's annoying.
Okay. A
It's a little faster than 11.8 right
now. Let's see if I can just get rid of
this overhead
and then we'll actually clean some stuff
up.
I just want to make sure we get a little
bit of PF out of all this pain that
we've gone through today. Uh, I'd like
to just get a little bit of PF out of
it. And at the very least, we'll know
once I've done this that it's it's set.
Yeah, you also have to have this thread
in it function, which is annoying, but
whatever. I kind of figured it would do
that cuz it needs to be a torch call,
which is stupid, but whatever.
Uh,
oops.
Okay. So, I mean, once we've done this,
I think that's basically all the
overhead we could possibly eat, right?
other than messing with um OM settings.
Other than messing with OM settings.
So,
I have no idea if this is even any of
the if this has like any overhead
edition whatsoever,
but
we'll do it.
And then this one's not needed anymore.
Yep.
What are you switching gears to? Just we
got it. Peru found it. I was being
stupid,
honestly.
I'm trying to wake up and do some
general clean up while we're doing this
one last thing and then I'm going to try
to do some general cleanup.
The hell
I forgot to update the sig. Oh, nope.
There it is. There's the sig update.
I I was forgetting to think after
updating the network. It was stupid.
When are you hiring that man? Yeah, I
know. I'm thinking about that. Like,
what problems do I have?
Exactly.
just give him some of the infrastructure
problems.
There's 12 11 9 or 12. All right. Well,
that's all the perf we're getting out of
it here. So
12 mil.
There might be some compile flags and
things we can find, but I think that's
I mean that's what we've got.
Uh let's get our profile things back in
here.
This will not do anything.
Oops.
Yeah, this should not change a thing.
This runs.
Click commit.
12 mil. Pretty much
Okay. Well, this was supposed to happen
like 5 hours ago,
but we should now start cleaning things
up,
right? We should start cleaning things
up.
Some of this will be clawed. Some of
this will be by hand.
We ditch multiple backends. I don't
think we do.
Try something.
Oh yeah, Spencer, are you here? Like if
you're here, the drive end at some point
would be nice to figure out. I can get
it cleaned up though a little bit more,
I think, before I ask you to look at it.
But I want I essentially I want that to
be one of our perk tests.
You can show those folks some cool
updates on 40.
Is it ready for look at? I mean, you can
look at it.
There's still weird things in buffer for
sure.
A See, this is a pain.
So, why is our new back end slower for
drive?
So 600.
If I do this one to two
new version 24 to go. Yeah, it's a
pretty awesome man.
What's the problem with the kernel?
Fixed
was stupid.
Just missing a sync.
Green light on an alpha test 40
huge PS was
I wanted it to be today, man, but like I
got stuck with the VE and I'm still
stuck. I fixed the threading. We got to
do some burp stuff
sadly and some clean up.
And I'm not going to make you look at
this mess
until we know it's stable.
Uh, has anybody tried just reweeping
that?
Go is actually like it's kind of like
chess and it's actually a pretty hard
end. It looks easy but it's not
to like I mean to code fast.
Uh both Spencer both will be faster for
the drive.
Okay. So this is actually as expected
this is faster.
So why
That's weird, right?
Especially at 1.24 mil.
Google is taking
mom. No,
Like it'll be useful for stuff, but not
for the stuff I'm doing.
It'll also just be hideously expensive,
but you know, unlimited Google money,
whatever.
I I don't understand why this is um
slower.
Are they using different numbers of
threads or something?
I can't just perf optimize all day.
I'm going to have to clean stuff up.
We'll just We just have to leave both
backends in for now, but that's fine.
latest drive with new bindings. It is
it's in 40.
I can commit the file right now because
I just I have commented like there's one
map right now by default. I can
uncomment the multim maps if you want. I
don't know what's easier to start with.
Yeah, the VEX speeds are a little
different. It's weird.
Binding C. Uh, there are still a whole
bunch of binding files. For now, they're
just an extension/name.c.
They're going to probably get moved back
to the original location and replace the
original ones though at some point,
depending on how we do stuff.
So you have multi map or single map. Uh
right now it's single. You can literally
just uncomment and rebuild. It's fast
scripts build vec drive
there. Like we have two options in
there.
I mean if you can get the thing to just
train on a map like that would be cool.
I just want to see what I screwed up.
I'm going to have this thing do like the
really coarse big refactors, I think,
and then I'm going to do the fine ones.
This is the moving [ __ ] around in 10
places variety.
the heck
for to update the uh the header I think.
Just update the header and this one.
Next thing it'll be is splitting this.
And then what else?
scraps. Maybe
quite a bit to do.
stream type. Fine. Uh, that's a little
sketchy.
I think it's a little sketchy.
We'll see how that goes.
Okay, that's ass. Let me just see what
uh what's going on. That's what it's
saying.
I'm starting to feel that I'm getting
lazy here. So,
I don't know.
But there's still so much more work to
do today. Oh, no. You're not doing void
star streams bastard.
What in the hell?
Just stream star.
Where is this thing to find?
Fine. Fine.
No on this.
We'll we'll do the fine grain stuff
after.
1%
neural networks basically code back how
do I train a basic RL
you follow my guide I have a very
detailed guide on X
uh the article
this one right here it'll sort you out
x.com/juarez
Yes.
Yeah. Yeah. We're just we're fighting
stupid thing. Um,
it's a very basic refactor, but
apparently I shouldn't have even let
this do that.
So, it goes and starts making void star.
I will come back to this though. I
I just don't want this to do like horse
grouping refactor. So, just like all the
things where you have to change stuff in
10 places because it's very stupid at
the moment. We're going to get that down
to be human editable and then I'm going
to do all the fine grain. It's the goal.
Okay. You know what?
Why do you need that?
It gets included, doesn't it?
This whole design is like garbage. All
right. Like I'm fighting with a few
different things at the moment that are
just like not letting me write good
code. And eventually I'm just going to
have everything ripped out anyways and
it'll be nice.
Like this entire thing is just
completely stupid.
How is it?
How is this so stupid? Like we had this
working before, right? It was literally
just This was like stupidly simple. No.
Oh, this is the wrong one. Hang on.
Yeah. So,
CUDA streamt, where did I have this
defined?
Okay.
purchase 390
What caves?
Um,
it's whatever the hell version of C tor
C++ torch uses.
I might honestly not want it to be a
shared library. This is so bad.
how bad this looks.
Uh, if I link it static, I don't know
how you include
there's not a reasonable way to train
many different environments
that I can think of if I do it static.
Like, you'd have to edit the source file
every time.
I mean, at least you don't have macro
hell with a shared library. Like, what
the hell is this?
PyTorch and C the share it's a C shared
library to be loaded in PyTorch
PyTorch C++ specifically.
This one's a mess, but we can just
refactor that.
See, I wanted to do this fresh today
while I was fresh, but like I just can't
think about this. I think we're going to
go to the main file and try to do some
stuff there for a little bit before
dinner, and I'll see if I maybe get a
little bit of energy back afterwards.
See if you can reimplement self play.
Not today, Jess. Not today.
We have stuff going on in the
background.
No, man. We're just not dealing with
that.
We're not going to deal with that.
What did expansion
actions?
There's
and then back. I don't keep up with this
crap.
I don't know. Whatever.
Yappity yappity yappity. Whatever people
do on Twitter.
Okay,
it's better.
Cool. I love how um Python makes
breaking changes to their packaging of
all things constantly.
the impulse worth binding.
See anything there is a problem.
No,
let's not do that.
Filter warnings is kind of bad. Anyways,
we'll just leave this one.
That was not any faster
for sure. Leave that alone.
debug symbol table. Okay, now that's
fine.
the model is very stupid no matter what
you do with it.
Um,
I it's honestly kind of gross I'm using
it as much as I am already.
The only thing I can say is like Torch
is awful and everything is super
verbose. So like whenever I need to edit
something, I have to edit something in a
bajillion places.
So my hope is that I can get this into a
format where I don't have to be using
the models as much as I am now.
Um, and I can just like cut out a good
chunk of this redundant crap because
it's really bad right now.
Like you see the cascading effect here.
It's just like the way that torches.
It's actually this isn't even that bad.
The kernel stuff is way worse because
you have to cascade through um the
additional torch modules layer. It's a
pain.
But this is basically um these types of
ops are basically like IDE refactors
barely more.
I'm going to have to think about the
shared library stuff as well. I'm not
happy with the shared library stuff one
bit.
Four buffers.
Not bad. I can have it move stuff
around.
Okay.
Create function for this.
I'm a little sketched by that. That
might be Cat being weird.
Easy.
It's better.
These are now nicely groomed.
I think I can do a lot of the moving
around manually. It'll be quicker than
even having this do it.
This has to go under name space, doesn't
it?
We have all these.
Does this need to be here? No. No, it
doesn't. Right. This can go down.
Okay, we still have a thousand lines of
code here, which is ridiculous.
Uh the impulse will have to stay for
like the couple different impulse will
have to stay for the time being.
Oh, it's this creative bowl is huge,
right?
Nutty.
It's very nutty.
I think we just start like tagging [ __ ]
for Claude. So
We're going to need these losses. Not
yet, though.
This might just be the the answer.
Honestly,
we just add a big binding file or
whatever.
Have everything be stupid shared
objects.
This
threats
so much stuff, man.
So much stuff.
I like doing this sometimes. It keeps me
more looking at the code rather than
just typing [ __ ] into claw.
Ridiculous. Yeah. 180 180 million bucks
of food and rent, I'm sure.
No, it's not.
This thing's really stupid, man. This
thing is really, really stupid.
I think it's slightly smarter than the
meta engineers though. So, you know,
we'll have the very stupid language
model um clean up the mess made by the
incredibly stupid meta engineers and
then I'll end up cleaning it up myself
from there to make something very nice.
That's probably what'll end up
happening.
They're paid like 600k.
Lo and behold, your salary is not very
well correlated with whether you're
worth a damn.
Lo and behold,
read any of the PyTorch source code and
tell me I'm wrong.
No pointer. No pointer. It's so freaking
bad, man. This is still so bad.
Honestly, I think I should just put in
some effort to figure out how to get
this stupid thing to compile faster.
I like this right.
Let me make sure it did it right.
Yes,
this is what I meant.
and it just hurts to look at.
It really does.
It's not commi at all. It's literally
just that the managers are also pretty
dumb. I mean, this just happens at every
big company, right? The companies try to
grow very quickly, they get big, and
they lose talent density, and they end
up wasting a bunch of money.
Anybody that has worked at a big company
that does not pride them themselves on
it will tell you the exact same thing.
Like a lot of what these fake companies
produce just hideously stupid.
You can It's like OpenAI did for several
years. You just can't grow super fast.
That's literally all it is.
Like basically as soon as you take a
huge amount of investment and have
pressure to do stuff super quick, like
that's it. You're done. Like you'll go
make a bunch of money, sure, but you're
not going to have the same level of
precision and clarity about everything,
right? And produce these like nice, very
understandable artifacts
um that smaller companies will. There's
just a lot of bloat
When you've literally spent half your
life on this stuff, like really really
getting good at something, it's like the
offer is no longer tempting at all.
like working at um one of those big
companies is basically the most
depressing [ __ ] I can imagine.
like I have done um like growing up I
have done manual labor jobs that were
more enjoyable than some tech
internships.
you have to risk your life. But still,
that one's a pretty uh tough cell on
that
Numb buffers total agents. Like
what is this crap? Right.
Everything is just super freaking
confused.
when will you be back Maryland? Probably
a couple months.
I do miss it. It's just freaking cold
right now.
Got a little code
little bit.
Hey, this is the great fight.
This is the fight that I was using for
the environment when I did that stupid
vibe coding stream.
The uh the agent figured out how to do
this exact thing basically instantly. I
didn't do the gear switching in the sim
though. But this like exact running
pattern where you take zero damage, it's
like an exploit of the way that the boss
turns its head.
This guy's doing it the super sweaty way
to show off for no reason to be fair.
There you go.
And you said you did not want to
download the game. Look. All right. I
earned a bit of a break
and X has been awful. So, I don't even
want to be spending my time like posting
stuff or, you know, viz and advertising
on X. It's just been gross lately. So,
I've been chilling. I've been just doing
this dev and chilling.
No, Jess, there's no skill involved with
it.
Like, I could use it more minimally, I
suppose, but honestly for MS, I I really
think that it's better to mostly code
them myself. Now, if I were to here, if
I were to use this for something like
that, it would be for a port.
So, if I were using this for a port uh
of existing code, for instance, there's
this TypeScript, the shitty TypeScript
sim of some of the Runescape
uh that I could do, but from scratch, I
think I would probably still just write
it.
It's fine.
Just easy graph code. We'll merge some
graphs after.
I think these are all just going to end
up getting mostly merged anyways.
I think I'm going to have to do um a bit
more work after dinner depending how I
feel.
There's just so much more to get done
here.
Oops. Hang on, guys.
Ah, damn it.
Got you. Yep.
All right. I got to go in five minutes
for dinner.
streaming Friday. No, Friday. Well, I
might stream a bit. We will see. I'm not
going to do the full day, though.
I don't know if I'm going to go running
just outside or if I'm going to go back
to the gym.
I definitely need to get my exercise
though for the week.
Saturday all day
I wonder if you can just graph this
entire thing.
We could probably get it to try doing
that.
I don't know if that would be better or
not, though.
We could probably save some redundant
copies. Actually,
yeah, I got some ideas on how we can
speed some stuff up still.
There's still some free perf on the
table.
Okay, still 11 mil.
We definitely uh we lost some perf, but
I know what we lost it on. Don't worry,
we lost it on the stupid shared
libraries.
That's the other thing I got to think
about.
So, there are a couple bigger things for
the refactor that I think will get us
per back as well.
I was going to say this file is getting
almost tolerable, but it's really not
yet.
There are a few projects, there are a
few like bigger refactors I'll try
flawed with, and I think once we have
like the final design of everything set
and all the enhancements. I think the
rest of it will just be by hand
Well, I got to go anyways, but I will uh
let me commit this real quick. And I got
to go get dinner.
Okay, I'm going to go get some food.
Depending how I feel, I might stream a
bit after dinner. We shall see. Uh,
thank you folks for tuning in
regardless. If you're interested in my
stuff generally and you'd like to
support my work for absolutely free,
feed the puffer star on GitHub. Helps
out a lot. Join Discord to get involved
with dev. We've got a lot of people in
here. started off pretty new and are now
very very talented. And uh and follow me
on next for more RL content.